[Music]
who
as I live and breathe The Wolverine I
need to go wishy washy combat my
constant you're not the only ones been
in a hand
she needs oil
she's very much like you let's not bring
out the worst in each other Logan rated
R
hey youtubers it's Charlie so WTF viral
clip just going to explain what's going
on it's basically an origin story there
were a lot of you that were wondering
why this is so pixelated it's meant to
look that way it's supposed to be like a
viral teaser like Oh somebody leaked
this on a thumb drive and now it's being
distributed just in the way they release
it as if somebody just randomly uploaded
it to the internet without giving it a
title like it's literally just a file
name of the file from the security
camera and that's probably what it is is
probably just security cam footage so
you see you're getting your adamantium
claws you see her freaking out this is
right out of the comic book and I should
actually say there's a new round of the
Logan giveaway for imax gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber we have a comment on
this video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so really glad they
actually did confirm this is being
released in imax the movie tivo actually
sent me something but I think I can say
what it is in a little while I haven't
gotten it in the mail yet because this
is still part of the continuities set up
by Xmen apocalypse you have to remember
that post credit scene where the ethics
corporation mr. Sinister's company
stoles a weapon x sample of Wolverines
blood the x 23 origin is completely in
keeping with the comic book storyline
and it ties up with the post credit
scene and apocalypse so there's one
sample of Wolverines DNA left this
version of weapon x has it there haven't
been any mutants born in the last 25
years so clearly they're trying to
reignite mutant kind but in their way as
people that they can control in pursuit
of that they try to clone Wolverine and
they wind up with Laura because they
have a damaged chromosome so she winds
up being female instead of just being a
straight-up copy of Wolverine so her
claws are a little bit different but the
scenes that you're seeing here is then
forcibly extracting her claws in bonding
them with adamantium that's what they
did in the comics so her entire skeleton
is an adamantium just her claws because
she was a little girl when she started
out in the comics she grew to be a young
woman that's how old she is in the
comics now so that explains how she's
able to grow like if Wolverine had been
bonded to his adamantium his entire
skeleton when he was a young child he
would be in a constant state of agony it
would prob
he drives him mad because the bones
wouldn't be able to grow beyond the
adamantium skeleton but his healing
factor would make sure that the bones
kept trying to grow you see you're
playing with her claws here she doesn't
seem too violent yet but I'm waiting for
them to release some clip where she
hooks out in this facility then takes
off because the person she's named after
dr. Kinney carried her to term raised
her in a very loving way as much as
possible in an environment like this so
she's relatively docile still exhibiting
some of Wolverines personality traits
but in the comics the thing that breaks
or the thing that makes her Hulk out and
go crazy on everyone is when xander rice
head of the program this character here
in the movie orders doctor Kenny's death
because she won't help turn x-23 into
the weapons that they want her to be so
she ones of dying x-23 hoax outbreaks
out and goes on a killing rampage on her
path to Wolverine so the movies changed
that a little bit it's aged her down at
the point of her breakout so that she's
more vulnerable she needs Logan's help
she's the reason why he pops the claws
again so to speak like you've seen that
sunseeker video with him just driving
the limo around random people in that
Vegas looking town like the worst
possible job that Wolverine could ever
have Jesus what has happened to him in
his old age this is terrible
[Music]
that's how bad things have gotten so
along comes a little girl he has to pop
the claws again okay finally I'll save
her but really the funny thing about all
this Professor X the cussing f bomb
dropping Professor X is the one who
takes the interest in her because he
detects who she is in what she needs for
the future of mutant kind remember no
new mutants in the last 25 years so even
though there are other mutants nearby
she is a new beginning for mutant kind
that kind of happened in the x-men
comics with the hope character during
the messiah complex storyline you don't
have to read that scarlet witch uses her
powers to say no more mutants and that's
the end of it obviously that didn't
happen in this universe is a slightly
different story but mutant kind is
completely wiped out until the birth of
Hope Summers so everyone treats her like
this messianic figure that's going to
save mutant so that's kind of who laura
is she is the hope of the comics for the
future of mutant kind in the movies but
we'll have to see what the bookend is
for this movie given that all the other
x-men movies that are coming even the
Deadpool movies will take place in the
past so most of the storytelling in the
x-men universe is going to be happening
between the 90s in between present day
this is so far in the future that you
don't need to worry too much about the
continuity they can have all the fun
that they want you know the movies can
do their thing they don't have to worry
about crossing the stream and I think
everybody would be totally cool if they
completely ignored the continuity of
this movie and then brought x-23 into
one of the newer x-men films down the
road even if it's not for a couple years
the rest of this footage gives you a
better look at the reverse they're all
cybernetically enhanced through the
weapon x program the idea of The Legend
of Wolverine is a big thing you have
both Laura her growing up learning about
them reading these comic book stories
The Legend of the x-men then you have
the villains to that know them by
reputation maybe they'd even cross paths
in the past so Logan talks about friends
dying in the real world it sounds like
even if Wolverine hasn't fought him
personally in the past he has history
with the other x-men maybe he killed
some of them I love the way they end
this too with that line of dialogue
let's not bring out the worst in each
other cut to the scene of the worst of
Wolverine coming out before he takes all
those dudes down so let me know in the
comments even if you haven't read that
hope summer storyline what do you think
that she means for the future of mutant
kind in this universe do you think that
she's the beginning of a new strain of
mutants I think they're going to be
pretty ambiguous with the way they end
the film because there's not going to be
a sequel to this if there's another
Wolverine film it'll be like some
crossover with Deadpool down the road or
it'll be a rebooted version of the
character with a different actor I think
even if Hugh Jackman changes his mind
about being Wolverine the most you could
hope for him coming back would be for a
Deadpool crossover or somewhat quick
cameo or just some funny nods in the
other x-men film but I'm not expecting
any of that anytime soon but anything
could change what's going to happen
tonight it is just because things would
so crazy with store this morning I'm
going to wait till tomorrow morning to
upload arrows and I'll do Black Panther
in my Legion video so there'll be three
videos tomorrow Black Panther arrow and
lija it's going to be crazy thank you so
much for watching while you wait for
that you can click here for the thor
ragnarok teaser and you can click here
for more Logan craziness everybody high
five I'll see you in the next video
you